six hommes 6 femmes les candidatures du
front national pour les élections
législatives respecte la parité des
retraités des jeunes travailleurs ou des
chefs d'entreprises déjà membre du parti
depuis plusieurs années notre but c'est
d'amener à l'assemblée nationale donc la
volonté de retrouver la souveraineté de
la france de voter toutes les lois
nécessaires pour retrouver cette
souveraineté
nous n'avons absolument pas ni des
partis traditionnels qui ont montré
leurs failles leurs failles ni des
pseudo parti en marche un nouveau issu
de la société civile qui ne représente
rien qu'ici on le sait très bien
dévaler des banques et des banquiers
donc nous sommes très confiants
candidate dans la 11e circonscription
mathilde andraud et sera opposé
notamment au député sortant et candidat
à l'élection présidentielle benoît hamon
la manière hostile à représenter les
yvelines et particules dans sa
circonscription
cristallise tous les soucis qu'on a
rencontré ces trente dernières années de
la lâcheté en politique et
l'abandon des français face à un qu un
communautarisme et gallopin territoire
rural autour de la zone urbaine de
rambouillet la 10e circonscription du
député sortant jean-frédéric poisson
le candidat du parti chrétien-démocrate
investi par les républicains présente
des similitudes avec le fn sur sa
conception de l'europe
ce qui n'inquiète pas le candidat du
parti de marine le pen le front national
lignes et lignes claires il monte
régulièrement dans la circonscription
par les 37% ce rambouillet enfin sur
l'ensemble du canton
c'est vrai on est en pleine ascension le
sud des yvelines le plus rural nous
donne quasiment la majorité lors des
élections législatives de 2012 le fn
avait obtenu son meilleur score dans la
9e circonscription avec plus de 18% des
voix les candidats yvelinois espère
surfer sur la dynamique qui pourrait
être enclenchée par marine le pen lors
de l'élection présidentielle